another candidate announced yesterday
did you know this Seth do nothing about
him Seth mom he's a congressman yeah
congressman another another candidate
announced ladies and gentlemen here's
the latest there are now 20 20 Democrats
running for president 20 bang bang yes
one more candidate and the fire marshal
is going to step in and shut it down
you clowns get out of here alright we're
gonna clear this hallway all right
Sanders get up off the floor come on we
picture him getting bad hair all over
the place that's also a chimpanzee I
don't know why that's my Sanders here's
the latest this is interesting a poll
taken of college students found that
their first choice for president is Joe
Biden and their second choice is Bernie
Sanders yeah apparently college students
are excited to not show up to vote for
either one
it's about apathy all right okay last
night Bernie Sanders said that even
people in prison should be allowed to
vote
yeah yes yes Bernie is building an
unusual constituency made up of
Millennials and Bill Cosby
so coming together oh you forgot about
him didn't you he's still in prison yeah
all right
meanwhile President Trump has big plans
in June did you hear this president
Trump is going to visit the United
Kingdom and have a state dinner with
Queen Elizabeth yeah yeah it'll be the
first time in history that buckingham
palace will order takeout from KFC
[Applause]